[Aplausos]
[Música]
the light of day' de suerte webber con
suerte
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas hasta donald
trump lo dijo boris johnson ha sido
tachado en numerosas ocasiones es algo
así como el trump de la política
británica y no se trata sólo de una
comparación estética y de que ambos
líderes generen constantemente un montón
de contenido para la prensa rosa porque
si sabemos que la vida privada de estos
dos personajes es de todo menos discreta
ambos se encuentran en su tercer
matrimonio y los dos llegaron al poder
teniendo cinco hijos que se sepa la
diferencia es que por lesión son entre
fiesta y fiesta ha tenido otros dos
vástagos en su tiempo como premier pero
es que acaso hay mejor fórmula para
combatir el envejecimiento de la
población británica y un baby boom en el
10 de downing street
[Música]
sea como sea la caída de johnson ha sido
particularmente llamativa teniendo en
cuenta que apenas dos años y medio antes
este primer ministro británico fue capaz
de cosechar un rotundo éxito electoral
la mayoría conservadora más grande desde
los tiempos de margaret thatcher una
caída sorprendente para un líder que en
septiembre del 2021 se imaginaba a sí
mismo como el primer ministro británico
de la época moderna que más tiempo
permanecería en el carbón boris johnson
contempla otra década en el poder apenas
unos meses antes de verse forzado a
dimitir johnson aspiraba a superar los
11 años de margaret thatcher en el poder
al final se ha quedado en tres años y un
poquito más así que la pregunta es cómo
se hizo con los mandos de downing
street- un tipo tan peculiar como
johnson que balance podemos hacer de su
etapa como primer ministro que ha sido
realmente lo que ha propiciado su caída
en este vídeo vamos a responder a todas
estas preguntas pero antes antes tenemos
que empezar por el principio tenemos que
ver un poco de historia
[Música]
y le importa la verdad
que boris johnson mintiera el parlamento
sobre su asistencia durante el
confinamiento a las fiestas celebradas
en downing street no pilló por sorpresa
a los que siguen de cerca la política
británica la trayectoria de johnson está
plagada de momentos en los que se peleó
con la verdad de hecho la falta de
compromiso con la verdad es quizás una
de las grandes manchas de este político
piensas que estoy exagerando pues no a
lo largo de la trayectoria profesional y
política de johnson esta mancha ha
estado siempre muy presente pero
empecemos por el principio tras estudiar
en el prestigioso etón college y luego
licenciarse en filología clásica en la
universidad de oxford johnson comenzó su
carrera profesional como periodista en
el 'times' medio del que fue despedido
por inventarse una cita tras este
altercado fue rescatado por el 'daily
telegraph' donde escribió columnas que
le empezaron a conectar con el
electorado conservador y a principios de
los 90 fue destinado como corresponsal a
bruselas donde comenzó a ganarse fama
por sus duras posiciones euroescépticas
eso sí esto fue algo que johnson hizo a
lo grande estuviera o no cargado de
razones su estilo recurrió siempre a la
exageración con el objetivo de
ridiculizar las instituciones
comunitarias en sus textos johnson llegó
a decir cosas como que la comisión
europea quería prohibir los cócteles de
gambas y las salchichas británicas o
incluso que buscaba estandarizar el
tamaño de los profilácticos porque los
italianos pues tenían órganos sexuales
más pequeños de regreso al reino unido-
continuó trabajando como columnista y se
presentó sin éxito a las elecciones a la
cámara de los comunes pero poco a poco
gracias a su trabajo y sobre todo a sus
continuas apariciones en el programa
high court news for you de la bbc
comenzó a ser una figura muy conocida le
ofrecieron entonces convertirse en
director de the spectator una revista
semanal sobre política cultura y asuntos
internacionales eso sí la condición es
que no se presentará como diputado lo
que johnson facto y por supuesto dos
años después incumplido como político se
ganó la confianza del entonces líder
conservador michael howard zinn quien al
poco tiempo éste le apartó después de
que los medios dejaran evidencia las
mentiras del bono de boris
lío de faldas otra de sus grandes
pasiones
[Música]
sea como sea el caso es que en 2008
boris johnson se convirtió en alcalde de
londres durante su mandato se pusieron
por ejemplo en marcha las obras del
'crossrail' un ambicioso tren de
cercanías del que ya os hablamos en
megaproyecto y lo cierto es que su
desempeño como alcalde le cosechó una
gran popularidad lo que le permitió
hacerse con la reelección una
popularidad que alcanzó el conjunto del
país también en la escena internacional
gracias a ser la afición de los juegos
olímpicos del año 2012
[Música]
en semejante contexto y gozando de unos
altísimos niveles de aprobación hizo lo
que mil veces había dicho que no haría
presentarse como candidato a las
parlamentarias del 2015 y así desde la
cámara de los comunes se convirtió en
una de las figuras más destacadas en
reclamar la salida del reino unido- de
la unión europea teniendo un papel
particularmente estelar en el referéndum
de 2016 por aquel entonces el partido
conservador llevaba seis años en el
poder con david cameron como primer
ministro os acordáis a que el referéndum
se convocó por muchos motivos pero esto
que veis en pantalla fue uno de los
argumentos principales y es que veréis
tras la gran recesión muchos políticos
economistas y expertos británicos que
eran escépticos con la unión europea
defendieron que la culpa de la pobre
evolución de la economía británica tenía
precisamente mucho que ver con el lastre
que suponía el club europeo
[Música]
johnson que se movía como pez en el agua
en este terreno fue desde el principio
uno de los grandes altavoces de esta
campaña campaña que no hace falta que os
recuerde fue todo un éxito y que terminó
con la propia dimisión de david cameron
sustituido por theresa may para hacer
cumplir el break ship johnson como
representante del ala más dura de los
partidarios del break city fue nombrado
ministro de asuntos exteriores y
permaneció en el cargo durante los dos
primeros años en los tres que duró este
gobierno un gobierno que fue un fracaso
theresa may que no creía en el presi no
consiguió prácticamente avanzar nada y
así entre dudas sobre si el break si
sería realmente posible le llegó la
oportunidad a nuestro protagonista de
este vídeo
el día 24 de julio del 2019 boris
johnson se convirtió en el primer
ministro del reino unido- de repente el
discurso cambió por completo y cinco
meses después en las elecciones del 12
de diciembre
boris johnson aplastó a todos sus
rivales en el reino unido- tenía un
nuevo emperador al menos en términos
políticos
[Música]
en la campaña electoral de boris johnson
en 2019 fue muy clara pidió el voto para
conseguir básicamente dos cosas llevar a
cabo el break sheets y mirar atrás e
impedir que jeremy corbyn el por aquel
entonces escorado muy a la izquierda
líder laborista se hiciera con el
gobierno británico fue todo un éxito a
los clásicos feudos conservadores se
sumaron muchos distritos de tradición
laborista que habían apostado
decididamente por el break city y que
además para ser justos pues no se
sentían particularmente entusiasmados
por el populismo de izquierdas del
candidato laborista
[Música]
y amigos amigas se podrán decir muchas
cosas pero en esta ocasión boris johnson
cumplió su palabra tras su aplastante
derrota corbin quedó fuera de la primera
línea política cuando parecía imposible
el primer ministro británico logró
cerrar un acuerdo con la unión europea
para que el break si se completara del
todo el 31 de enero del 2020
[Música]
es verdad que el acuerdo no fue
precisamente el deseado por los
hooligans de un break si duro puesto que
irlanda del norte continúa perteneciendo
al mercado único europeo de mercancías
algo que desde entonces ha sido un
enorme quebradero de cabeza una
inagotable fuente de conflictos
políticos porque pues porque pertenecer
al mercado europeo de mercancías
conlleva no formar parte del propio
mercado británico esta frontera
comercial en el mar de irlanda incomoda
a muchos en gran bretaña e incluso el
propio johnson amenazó con frecuencia
con romper el llamado protocolo de
irlanda y eso no es todo el break sheet
es una oportunidad pero también un
riesgo que salga mejor o peor en el
medio y largo plazo dependerá
esencialmente de las políticas que
adopten el gobierno británico esto
parece de cajón verdad el problema el
problema es que se vendió otra cosa
muchos líderes progressive incluido el
propio johnson pintaron que todo sería
un camino de rosas que la mera salida de
la unión europea supondría algo así como
meter el turbo en la economía y que de
repente todos serían más y más prósperos
pero la realidad es la contraria
a corto plazo el presi de mucha
incertidumbre y la necesidad de llevar a
cabo un sinfín de ajustes que ralentizan
la economía por ejemplo según datos del
centro para la reforma europea hasta
ahora el break sheet ha supuesto para el
reino unido- una caída en la inversión y
el comercio del 10 por ciento frente a
un crecimiento mundial del 6% si a medio
y largo plazo puede ser una gran
oportunidad pero eso requerirá tiempo
paciencia y sobre todo políticas que
mejoren la competitividad británica y
aquí aquí johnson tampoco ha estado
particularmente a la altura ha
presentado muchos grandes planes
interesantes pero a la hora de la verdad
se ha ejecutado y ha avanzado muy poco y
en cambio lo que sí ha hecho ha sido
gastar a manos llenas e incrementar los
impuestos a las empresas y eso eso es
algo que también ha contribuido a
erosionar su peso dentro del movimiento
conservador pero no sólo podemos hablar
del éxito y sus consecuencias la era del
johnson nos deja muchas más historias
atentos
[Música]
las medias verdades como política
amigos amigas la política exterior ha
sido con mucha diferencia el ámbito en
el que más se notan los cambios
provocados por el presi mientras la
maquinaria europea acostumbra a ser
lenta y pesada londres ha ganado mucha
agilidad a la hora de fijar su posición
en los grandes temas de la escena
internacional lo que ha hecho que el
propio police johnson sea ahora mismo
más querido en el extranjero quien en su
propio país mira por ejemplo quién fue
el que más alegro de que johnson
superará en junio una moción de censura
y acceso del programa de adoración son
real y truco creíble y ya la segunda son
seguros denominados bretaña nada
simbólico brujo efectivamente el reino
unido está apoyando a ucrania sin
fisuras de hecho en ucrania están tan
agradecidos con boris johnson que le han
dedicado una calle en la ciudad de
odessa y seguramente no sea la última
luego el acuerdo august entre australia
eeuu y el reino unido- supuso otra gran
victoria diplomática algo así como
londres está de vuelta en la escena
internacional
las buenas noticias se terminan
prácticamente aquí
y es que veréis otro ámbito en el que al
final consiguió un destacado liderazgo
fue en la gestión en la pandemia el
gobierno británico apostó firmemente por
las vacunas y logró tasas de vacunación
similares a las que consiguió israel en
las primeras etapas del proceso de
vacunación algo que también hizo que los
partidarios del presidente echó con
gráficos como es
[Música]
claro que no todo el salió también a
nivel nacional su política estrella fue
la conocida como level in up algo así
como subir y equilibrar su objetivo
pasaba por lograr un mayor desarrollo
económico en las midlands de inglaterra
en galés en irlanda del norte y en
escocia es decir en todas aquellas
partes del país que no han logrado
tantos éxitos como el área metropolitana
de londres y las grandes ciudades
inglesas la idea era incrementar mucho
la inversión pública en estos
territorios
[Música]
durante décadas el gobierno británico ha
hablado de reducir las desigualdades
entre el dinamismo de londres y el sur
de inglaterra con el resto de los
territorios al respecto se ha hablado
mucho pero lo cierto es que se ha hecho
más bien poco y con escaso éxito la hit
y sigue concentrando lo todo y además
todo indica que así seguirá siendo por
el momento
pues bien apostar por el level in app
acarreaba a un aliciente añadido para
johnson su mayoría absoluta- supuso para
los tories obtener diputados en los
lugares más insospechados y esto esto ha
generado dos grandes corrientes en el
partido conservador a la clásica
corriente liberal de los tories de
londres y del sureste se ha unido otro
movimiento uno muy conservador pero
mucho más intervencionista el del norte
y las midlands que reclaman un fuerte
incremento del gasto público y ahí ahí
es donde johnson quiere apostar buena
parte de su capital político y para ello
el gobierno tenía que movilizar enormes
cantidades de inversión pública el
problema por supuesto es que los
recursos no son infinitos amigos los
planes de estímulo para apoyar la
recuperación post cobit junto a los
costes de la propia candem ya y del
resto de planes del gobierno han traído
consigo algo que sería duramente
condenado por la propia margaret
thatcher reino unido se encuentra entre
las primeras naciones occidentales en
aumentar los impuestos para cubrir los
costes de lakovic 19 amigos el sistema
británico de salud no pasa por su mejor
momento las listas de espera se
multiplican y afectan a millones de
pacientes y como el crecimiento
económico está lejos del esperado y aún
más lejos del prometido durante la
campaña de albert exit boris johnson
buscó incrementar sus recursos tirando
de todo un clásico subir los impuestos
de esta forma incremento la fiscalidad
sobre las nóminas de los trabajadores en
dos puntos y medio a repartir a partes
iguales entre las empresas y sus
empleados además el impuesto de
sociedades- pasará del 19 al 25 por
ciento en abril del 2023 el encargado de
impulsar estas medidas fue risk y son
aquí el canciller de hacienda que al
parecer se oponía a financiar las
expansiones de gasto completamente con
deuda sea como sea lo que está claro es
que los planes de estímulo puede
resultar más o menos populares pero
suben los impuestos es algo que no le
gusta a casi nadie sobre todo en el lado
conservador y mucho menos en un momento
como éste la inflación del reino unido
alcanza un nuevo máximo en 40 años del
94 por ciento a medida que se profundiza
la crisis del coste de la vida y luego
está la crisis de la energía y las cada
vez más altas facturas que reciben los
hogares británicos así que claro las
promesas incumplidas los desengaños la
inflación y la subida de impuestos han
terminado por erosionar y mucho el
capital político de boris johnson y sus
apoyos dentro del partido conservador
claro que su dimisión ha tenido mucho
más que ver con su comportamiento
personal que con él hasta ahora mediocre
rendimiento logrado atentos
[Música]
y el engaño como métodos de
supervivencia
a estas alturas tampoco merece la pena
entrar en muchos detalles respecto a
todas las idas y venidas de boris
johnson con el escándalo del partido y
por cierto podemos dejar ya de poner la
coletilla está del gate a cualquier
escándalo vamos ni que el watergate
hubiera sido un escándalo relacionado
con el agua en fin el caso es que con el
tema de la fiesta intento engañar a los
británicos al parlamento y a todo el
mundo la realidad es que en mayo del
2020 un montón de altos cargos del
gobierno se juntaban en los jardines de
downing street para tomar su tradicional
vino de los viernes mientras el resto de
los británicos tenía prohibido
socializar y hacer prácticamente
cualquier cosa que no fuera estar en
casa y se acaso en el trabajo así que
podéis imaginaros la indignación que
provocaron noticias como esto
boris johnson es multado por la
publicidad por incumplir el
confinamiento con fiestas en las
instalaciones del gobierno del reino
unido ante esto johnson llegó a decir
que bueno que es que nadie le había
avisado que asistir a aquellos eventos
que incumplía las normas de
distanciamiento social aprobadas por su
propio gobierno como podéis imaginar
ante una tomadura de pelo hubo muchos
tories que empezaron a retirarle su
apoyo al primer ministro johnson puso en
marcha entonces la llamada 'operación
red y un intento desesperado de
recuperar el apoyo de los suyos
esta operación carne roja e incluida
política es tan disparatadas como
entregar el control del canal de la
mancha de la royal navy que no cuenta
con las embarcaciones adecuadas para
combatir la inmigración ilegal también
un acuerdo para deportar a los
sinpapeles a países africanos como
ruanda o nigeria algo que hizo que el
propio príncipe carlos de inglaterra
dejara a un lado su neutralidad para
calificar esta política como espantosa
[Música]
y así y johnson fue perdiendo la
confianza de los tories hasta el punto
de que a principios de junio de 2022 se
presentaron una moción de censura
johnson consiguió superar la moción pero
su gobierno quiero herido de muerte y la
puntilla al primer ministro la dio el
escándalo pincher crispín chair era un
alto cargo del grupo parlamentario del
partido conservador que emitió a finales
de junio al ser acusado de agredir
sexualmente a dos hombres el escándalo
estalló al saberse que pincher había
sido nombrado para esta responsabilidad
por boris johnson a pesar de que éste ya
conocía que arrastraba acusaciones
similares de la etapa de ambos en el
ministerio de asuntos exteriores el
escándalo pincher provocó la dimisión
inmediata del canciller de hacienda
risas una y también del ministro de
sanidad sayid gbit que fue muy elocuente
ante el parlamento para definir la
deriva que estaba tomando johnson
mix del fútbol es una posición del
hardware balls i like that shakes la
dimisión de estos dos ministros fue el
principio del fin
en apenas 36 horas renunciaron a sus
responsabilidades hasta 50 altos cargos
del gobierno y ese ese fue el final al
menos por ahora de boris johnson y digo
por ahora porque ya hay rumores de que
el líder británico se ha propuesto
volver a la primera fila para recuperar
el trono que le han arrebatado sea como
sea su despedida en el parlamento
británico no dejó indiferente a nadie
sí
hasta la vista
[Aplausos]
hasta aquí turno para ti que recuerdo
dejar en tu memoria boris johnson qué
consejo le darías al futuro primer
ministro británico déjanos tu respuesta
abajo en los comentarios como siempre si
te resulta interesante este vídeo no
olvides darle al botón de like y
compartirlo con tus amigos un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]